ein auto knallt mit highspeed gegen
einen brückenpfeiler und fängt feuer was
tödlich hätte enden können wurde zur
heldengeschichte und die retter die sind
noch ganz ganz junge
heute nacht in potsdam heldenmut im
angesicht des feuers zu lebensrettern
wurden fünf junge menschen wie
selbstverständlich retteten die vier
männer und eine frau einen 64 jährigen
fahrer aus seinem brennenden pkw nachdem
dieser gegen das fundament einer
eisenbahnbrücke geprallt war die jungen
ersthelfer darunter zwei
sanitätssoldaten der bundeswehr
versorgten den schwerverletzten senior
danach weiter bis zum eintreffen der
rettungskräfte der 64 jährige war aus
noch ungeklärter ursache in potsdam golm
auf dem werder schon damm gegen die
massive betonmauer der dortigen
eisenbahnbrücke geprallt der kleinwagen
fing nach dem aufprall sofort feuer die
vier jungen leute im alter von 18 bis 21
jahren kam unmittelbar danach an die
unfallstelle der fahrer war gerade dabei
aus dem brennenden pkw zu kriechen
sofort zogen die fünf den mann in die
sichere entfernen und alarmierten
rettungskräfte
die feuerwehr löschte den brennenden pkw
der völlig ausbrannte und er ebenfalls
eintreffende rettungsdienst übernahmen
die weitere versorgung des unfallfahrers
für die jungen helfer waren die
professionellen retter voll des lobes
und bedankten sich für die hervorragende
hilfe warum es zu dem unfall kam
ermittelt nun die polizei wenn man noch
ran kommt dann die personen und ein
bisschen weiter vom feuer weg ziehen
kann das ist immer gut weil feuer ist
für den körper so nicht so nicht so gut
und so wird sind erste helfer natürlich
wichtig aber selber tv muss ich nicht
bringen
um die person zu retten weil manchmal
kommt man nicht mehr ran es freut mich
dass er dann in einen rettungswagen
schnell eingetragen worden dass die
kräfte auch schnell vor ort waren
wir realisieren dass jetzt gerade so ein
bisschen was nach einer geraucht noch
kurz gequatscht und
ja wie ist denn das gefühl das war die
letzte frage die wir gerade noch gehört
haben und da fragen wir noch jetzt
direkt richard marshall ist unser
zugeschaltet einen der retter aus der
nacht wie fühlt man sich als ein held
der nacht
guten tag ja anhält der nacht ich sag
mal was jetzt was bedeutet hält wir
haben getan was wir konnten und man hat
natürlich ein schönes gefühl danach ja
was ging dir als erstes durch den kopf
als du diesen unfall gesehen hast was
denkt man in so einem moment
ja schwierig in dem moment kann man das
gar nicht realisieren also ich kam mit
dem auto angefahren richtung unfallort
und habe dann von beiden schon ein ja
sag mal wie ein feuerball gesehen und
man realisiert den momenten in dem
moment halt gar nicht dass es wirklich
ein brennendes auto ist wenn man das ja
wirklich nicht alle tage hat und sind
dann halt auf den unfall drauf
zugefahren denn sofort auch angehalten
sind dennoch auf zwei andere jugendliche
getroffen von der bundeswehr
und ja sind denn zur tat geschritten die
flammen sind natürlich unerträglich heiß
so ein auto brennt man sieht da ist ein
mensch in lebensgefahr trotzdem hat man
natürlich auch angst
selber sozusagen dann schaden zu nehmen
wie hast du diese angst überwunden oder
war das einfach ein reflex
ja und zwar war es halt so dass wir zum
glück also zum glück hatte der der
ältere herr sich schon so halb aus dem
auto selber gerettet und wir konnten
ihnen also einmal aus dem
gefahrenbereich heraus ziehen raustragen
so dass wir von den flammen geschützt
war und ich sag mal die flammen heißt ja
das ist richtig die sind sehr heiß bloß
sie mussten auch nicht direkt
unmittelbar in oder an das auto ist ja
der kreis wurden lag waren ungefähr 5
meter wir haben den bis zu 15 meter
entfernt weißt du wie es den mann jetzt
geht und werdet ihr euch nochmal treffen
ja ich hoffe dass es dem land gutgeht
genau das kann ich gar nicht sagen ich
weiß da glaube ich genauso viel wie sie
da draußen
und ja wenn es ihnen dann bei deinem gut
geht dann denke ich mal dass man sich
bestimmt aber wieder sehen wird dann
natürlich schön ja super vielen dank
unser held des tages